welcome back to my M night Shyamalan
series guys I'm reviewing a select few
of his films leading up to his next film
the visit this September I've already
covered the sixth sense if you want to
check that out it's on my channel right
now
his next film is my answer whenever
someone says hey Chris what's a really
underrated movie unbreakable when you
have a hit as big as the sixth sense I'm
talking critics loved it audiences loved
it the Academy Awards loved it it's
really hard to go anywhere but down
after that because you are always going
to be living up to a certain expectation
coming off that success with another
original movie that's extremely hard to
market unbreakable never really found
its audience in the early 2000s however
if you ask people nowadays what their
favorite M night Shyamalan film is a
surprising amount of people respond with
unbreakable now as a warning similar to
my review of The Sixth Sense this review
is going to contain some spoilers I've
warned you unbreakable is about a man
named David Dunn played by Bruce Willis
he was involved in a very unfortunate
train accident and he was the only
survivor but not only was he the only
survivor he emerged without a single
scratch and this makes samuel l.jackson
character elisha prince extremely
skeptical because he's been searching
for a man like this for almost his
entire life elisha suffers from a rare
disease in which his bones can easily be
broken his arms and legs were broken
right out of the womb that's disturbing
as hell but it was a very chilling
opening scene and a great way to set the
serious tone of what is actually a
superhero movie in hiding and Elijah
believes that there's someone on the
opposite end of his spectrum someone who
can't be hurt someone who's impervious
to pain someone who is technically a
superhero now unbreakable came out in
the year 2000 a very important year for
comic book movies because up until then
we'd had the Superman films we'd had the
Batman films but they were in this sort
of weird like we can do these guys
because they're popular and we'll see
what we can do you know like people
weren't like oh my god comic book movies
can happen I spent my childhood
wondering if we'd ever see an Incredible
Hulk film we'd ever see a spider-man
film if we'd ever see an x-men film
which is what happened in the year 2001
and singer so excellently brought the
x-men to life but as you guys know today
comic book movies are everywhere they're
the most popular genre in film right now
in regards to box office gross and a
movie like unbreakable is the kind of
movie that a really smart director would
make today in the Year 2015
critics would go and see it and go wow
what a breath of fresh air from the
everyday comic book movie to see this
serious take on the genre except it was
made 15 years ago before the explosion
happened which makes it all the better
now as you guys saw in my review of The
Sixth Sense I love that movie and this
may be an unpopular opinion but I like
unbreakable even more I think it's a
better film in almost every way I think
it's better acted I think it's better
directed I think that as a story it's
infinitely more interesting and even
more original than The Sixth Sense was
because The Sixth Sense has great ideas
and it's a very effective movie with
terrific virtually everything but I
found unbreakable to be an infinitely
more watchable movie with far more
replay value so let's analyze this thing
after the opening credits we get this
incredible one take on a train with
Willis and you learn so much about him
instantly you see him take off his
wedding ring as a cute girl approaches
we hear him talking about his fear of
water you learn almost every major point
you need to know about David Dunn in one
take as a self-professed comic book fan
Shyamalan looked at these characters the
hero and the eventual villain which was
revealed in the twist which we'll talk
more about later and he gave them both
signature colors Elijah's is purple in
his office the walls are painted purple
most of the clothes he wears throughout
the movie have purple involved in some
way David Dunn's character is green the
security poncho that he wears when he's
at his job at the University Stadium as
a shade of green quite often the clothes
that he is wearing as a shade of green
as well as the way his house is directed
these subtle things have virtually no
effect on the story but what I really
appreciate about it is that it shows
that Shyamalan was really really trying
with this movie I mean he put so many
small details that have virtually no
impact on how the story plays out but he
did it as a way to tribute comic book
characters in fact a lot of the shots in
the movie were designed to look as if
they were comic panels I was watching
the document
making of the film and Willis was
talking about how quite often they would
just do everything in one take and he
would only do it a couple times and it
was actually making people nervous
because they were afraid they weren't
getting enough coverage but when he
watched the movie and you see these long
takes playing out it reminds me of that
old-fashioned style of filmmaking in
which a take would show many actors are
just a couple actors in a shot
conversing with one another and you can
see these actors are actually acting in
a space it's not just cut to a close-up
cut to a close-up cut to a close-up it's
one big shot in which you can actually
get a feel for the world and unbreakable
did that beautifully now from a dramatic
perspective I honestly think this is the
best work that Bruce Willis has ever
done he is magnificent in this movie
he's so subtle he's very subdued he's
quiet but you can feel a world of pain
for things that happened to him in his
past with this accident in which he was
supposedly injured and then quit
football he feels he hasn't been a good
father to his son played by Spencer
treat Clark who's also really good in
the movie another very good child
performance let's talk about samuel
l.jackson who looks like a crazy person
and he is a crazy person so it works
again we'll talk about that twist soon
but as a character elisha prince is a
fascinating individual he has this rare
disease that does exist in real life and
so you automatically feel very sorry for
him but the way samuel l.jackson plays
this character he's so stubborn about
his beliefs and he's so strong as a
character because of all the things he's
been through that you actually begin to
respect him I want to talk about what is
perhaps my favorite scene in this movie
it's the workout scene in his basement
David Dunn is working out and his son is
secretly adding more weight trying to
see if his father is really the
superhero that Elijah thinks he is and
as the scene progresses they continue to
add more and more weight and it just
gets funnier and funnier and the editing
of this scene really makes the comedy
pop and it's one of the best scenes in
the whole movie as the film progresses
and David realizes that he can't
remember ever being sick he's stronger
than he ever was he survived this crazy
train wreck he begins to think that
maybe Elijah is actually right maybe he
is a superhero and I'm not laughing when
I'm watching this there's no laughing it
like on paper it's like this is the
dumbest thing I've ever read especially
in the year 2000 when he was trying to
sell this movie but they made it
cuz of the success of The Sixth Sense
and my god like 15 years later this
movie has held up so well the marketing
of the movie was like it's a
supernatural movie it's a suspense scary
film something's weird happened with
this guy who knows but the movie was
really about Superman in hiding in fact
one of my all-time favorite directors
Quentin Tarantino said that unbreakable
was not only one of the masterpieces of
our time but what it should have been
marketed as was what if Superman was on
earth and he didn't know he was Superman
and that is a great idea because that's
really what this movie is about it's
about someone who has some secret inside
of him that he is feeling like something
has to happen with my life why don't I
feel happy it's because he's not doing
what he's meant to do and what he's
meant to do is be a fucking superhero
now I got to talk about James Newton
Howard holy shit the scene in which he's
going after the orange man the man who
killed this person and is now keeping
these girls chained up somewhere and he
falls into the pool and gets caught in
that tarp and then starts to drown
because of course he realizes his
weakness is water water is his
kryptonite and when the girls pull him
out and he stands up that frickin score
oh my god I just want to take my fist
and pump it into the air and when he
headlocks the guy and they start having
the struggle and it's like this one-take
rising up into the air of him just like
taking this guy down to the ground and
the music is so fucking inspirational
you just feel like yes this is the first
time this guy is doing what he's
supposed to do he is saving these girls
you just feel it that score is so good
I'm telling you guys that moment in film
is one of the most inspirational things
I've ever seen in a movie and it's a guy
getting choked out like how crazy is
that but it's true because you realize
this is what the character is meant to
do he's meant to save people he's meant
to be that one person on earth who can
actually make a difference and James
Newton Howard score combined with the
editing and the directing and the
performances and the stunt work in that
scene it's one of my favorite movie
scenes of all time and I love the fact
that his security cloak eventually
becomes his superhero costume so let's
talk about the twist ending of
unbreakable because for some people it
makes or breaks the film I think it's
fantastic and not just because of
what it means for the story the thing
that most people talked about in the
sixth sense was the twist and that's
what got more people to go back and see
it again to see the film in a different
way it's what gave the film word of
mouth so when you go to a film like
unbreakable people suddenly have these
expectations in fact I'm actually very
disheartened by the Rotten Tomatoes
consensus of this film with a weaker
ending unbreakable is not as good as The
Sixth Sense
the reason this kind of hurts me a
little bit is because as a critic I try
to never fall into the whole Hollywood
hype expectations thing and it
disheartens me that critics at the time
in the year 2000 did that it's like we
just wanted to see what the twist was
and oh it wasn't as surprising as a
sixth sense well this movie isn't as
good as a sixth sense so it's just not
as good because the twist isn't as good
it's a completely different movie in
every way to compare it to the sixth
sense is so fucking dumb just because
it's made by the same director you don't
compare completely different films and
say one of them isn't as good simply
because the ending wasn't as good as the
last one what Elijah says at the end of
this movie is that you can always tell
who the villain is going to be because
he's the exact opposite of the hero and
sometimes they're friends like and
unbreakable the ending of unbreakable
works on almost every level once you
discover that Elijah was the one who was
setting up various disasters one of the
biggest complaints I've heard about the
ending is that it feels a little
unnecessary which I can understand
because it doesn't necessarily feel
warranted or earned on the first viewing
because it feels totally out of left
field but when Yuri watch the movie
multiple times and you see hints that
Elijah being the person who's behind all
this
it really fits together very nicely also
the movie needs a villain and that
villain is eventually revealed to be
Elijah now look at most comic book
superheroes it's a very common trend in
comic books the villain is almost always
directly involved with the creation of
the superhero and unbreakable tells the
same story it's fucking genius guys
unbreakable is one of my all-time
favorite movies I actually like it more
than the sixth sense I think that over
time the film is actually quietly
improved it's gotten better with repeat
viewings and I got a giv unbreakable and
a-plus
if you've never seen this movie
first off why'd you watch this review
it's all spoilery but anyway definitely
check out unbreakable it's a great film
I think it's very underrated and very
overlooked my next M night Shyamalan
review is not going to be signs because
I've already done like a 30 minute
in-depth analysis of signs I have
nothing else to say about it that videos
on my channel right now if you want to
check it out it's called signs analyzed
my next review is going to be for the
village which is a very polarizing
Shyamalan film and I'm excited to talk
to you guys about it because that was
one of my most anticipated movies of all
time back in the day guys thank you so
much as always for watching I greatly
appreciate it and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes